après une crise existentielle et une
dépression la pianiste alexandra
stréliski à créer un album instrumental
émouvant
j'ai fait j'ai ce qu'on appelle un
burnout et ça m'a amené à me poser
beaucoup de questions à me remettre en
question met à chercher plus de sens
dans ma vie puis cet album là est né de
cette de cette période transitoire
né à montréal alexandra stréliski a
appris le piano un très jeune âge mais
c'est à 29 ans qu'elle gagne en
popularité
lorsque le réalisateur jean-marc vallée
choisi une de ses pièces pour son film
dallas buyers club
et lorsque ma tous mes conneries reçoit
l'oscar du meilleur acteur
c'est la musique d'alexandra streamiz
qui compte en temps
[Musique]
c'était très drôle parce que moi je ne
savais pas que ça allait jouer donc j'ai
été surprise j'ai entendu c'est un
orchestre ige une très grosse surprise
même pour vrai jeu ma première réaction
c'est et comment
mais on suit pendant ma toune puis après
ça s'est mis un défilé puis j'ai eu des
appels
jean marc vallée a aussi utilisé la
musique de la pianiste pour les séries b
[ __ ] live écharpe abject
la musique d'alexandra stréliski est
cinématographique et elle n'est pas sans
rappeler celle du film la leçon de piano
c'est sûr que les compositeurs
classiques chopin et moi je suis né je
suis pianiste classique de formation ça
m'a beaucoup influencé mais aussi les
compositeurs de film nine dans les airs
[Musique]
germanium tous les compositeurs les
grands compositeurs de musique de films
moins forcée d'une manière ou l'autre
avec son nouvel album intitulé n.skep
alexandra stréliski espère voyage est
encore bien loin ici
oui j'ai pris mes bras du canada
montréal
[Musique]